[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god you're so funny
thank you my god I love you meet Norman
Lear he was I'm so strong he was
cracking up her butt crack not watching
you here daughter still I love it I'm
between two legends no not the same
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
your accent reminds me of home I always
live it I run into you my it just feels
so where did you grow up I grew up in
North Carolina my mom made me be a
debutante that's how slow you're a
southern belle you're a southern belle
wait what did that entail what did you
have to do oh my gosh you are so fancy
right now y'all had to wear white oh my
god you were from like the bricks I was
from the sticks girl we didn't have
anything like that yeah
but we had no money I that was the thing
my mom had been one and then we lost all
our money gambling then she still wanted
me to carry on this tradition of being
uh pretending to be rich and then go to
etiquette classes I don't have my face
with a napkin and you know you can't
wipe your face like a monster obviously
I didn't attend I still to this day
people are like you should never eat in
public what did your family think
whenever you told them they're gay cuz
forming from the south that is not
always an easy conversation yeah I mean
I I think my mom for her she just like
she don't want my life to be harder than
then what life can be you know already
already but you know we have this really
poignant moment I talked about it in my
special where I told her I was gay and
she was like stone-faced and I was like
oh man does she like hate me now and she
was like we are going to Hooters
[Laughter]
of being like I accept you let's go to
heaters I told my dad he was like you
know he's a very typical southern man is
very simple and he's like okay all right
well you also buy you a men's blazer top
hat it's mine like if I'm like minion
you want to dress like a man like okay
let's get you that top hat wager it's
kind of amazing though being from this
side that they were accepting cuz I know
a lot of I have a lot of friends
actually or a few friends that they
didn't say let's go to Hooters they said
let's go to church and they wanted to
pray for him and like change them
straight or something and I'm like I
don't think your prayer is gonna make
him straight just say yeah yeah so it's
it can be hard for people a hundred
percent I mean it you know we've come a
long way but there's still plenty of
people who you know are just owned by
their families and I'm so lucky that my
family awesome yeah they were just like
we love you no matter what you are no
different than you were yesterday you
talked about speaking of Hooters you
talk about Hooters in your net big
special a lot so like are they are they
close to your heart because I haven't in
if you well I don't know if you're aware
but I just won The Voice recently with
Jake hoot
it's all about some Jake who Hooters was
so supportive all about yes I'm just
saying there yes he's I've been talking
about Hooters my entire career you just
needed the voice I just needed the
platform in the voice I was even a
Hooters waitress not for real for comedy
back in the day i wanted the outfit and
everything listen they wear pantyhose so
they are keeping it classy put the
pantyhose super classy in my special
instill there's like who and so I'm
doing whatever I can to keep Hooters
legacy a lot we're gonna we're getting
my specialist on Netflix right now yeah
so Larry I know you're busy you're
creating we can do one together oh my
gosh please can you call it herders if
you have any other plans like big plans
for 2020 oh man are you get married I am
it I I my fiance is here in the audience
Schwimmer
I did she's wait in the corn it'd be
excellent yeah bring this point for my
nobody puts Baby in the corner
[Laughter]
married hopefully I mean that's the plan
right yeah I'm very excited I make
vision boards every year I know my buddy
Ron Funches was on your show yes he
brought his vision board I didn't want
to copy I didn't copy him but I have my
own visions I hoping in 2020 I mean I
won't people to watch my special for
sure but I'm I'm really wanting to get I
put it on my Instagram one of those
there's a Tom Cruise cake I don't know
if you guys is it like his face everyone
so Tom Cruise whenever he works with
somebody or he if someone's done
something for them he he sends in this
coconut cake from downes bakery and I
went down this rabbit hole of Google and
learned everything I could about this
cage all in one life is for Tom Cruise
to send me a Tom Cruise coconut cake
[Applause]
2020 vision board dreams are about to
come true slightly oh yeah because I
don't I'm not that cool so you know Tom
Cruise isn't here but we got you the
cake
I just yes okay exactly hey I have a
Vegas special don't you threaten me with
a good time you you come on out and say
any time you want I can play the
triangle why did I give myself okay
girls ding let's see Tom Cruise what
your cake is like Tom Cruise thank you
Tom Cruise do this I mean Tom has no
idea this is happening no oh my gosh
okay that's not all y'all gettin some
cake
[Applause]
it's so good yeah we don't need Tom
Cruise we could buy our own cake are you
guys know are you guys done I have to be
done cuz I have to talk right now
oh but trust that we'll end up in my
dressing room yeah I'm done to me just
alright well you can watch fortune
beamster sweet and salty on Netflix now
and don't miss her subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going